what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba's
I'm John Humphrey hope you subscribe
like this video I'll say that first we
have been waiting for this trailer for
awhile all of us together two years
Ender's Game trailer is finally here we
actually have several reactions from e3
already shot and edited ready to go up
we wanted to make sure people got
notified about this one because is our
most anticipated as well as most
people's enough chitchat and let's get
to it shall we
[Music]
Avengers day
The Avengers were everything I imagined
[Music]
Thor told me check it out once
it's just got a whole lot more
[Music]
[Music]
like this quick secure the bridge
so what's your status
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
five years later do the Avengers pose a
danger to society that was the Boston
Bruce Oh
[Music]
I was reborn it
oh damn
who is the happy end I'll have to go
frame-by-frame and figure it out cool
yeah it looks really fun man I can't
wait to play as all them maybe we didn't
get much gameplay in here I want to see
more gameplay because part of what gets
me excited and I think especially coming
off of this Spider Man ps4 game which
I've been playing recently I'm I'm the
kind of guy who slowly makes his way
through video games and I almost fireman
ps4 and I've been playing instead of how
great that game isn't even though I know
it's not you know the MCU Spider Man
like these feel direct deviations from
the MCU I feel very close yeah like a
weird effort to make it very reminiscent
but not exact because now their face is
exactly matched like the facial hair and
stuff for EDIUS similarities together
and also the members they chose
excluding Hawkeye screw Hawkeye get him
out of here what do we need Hawkeye in
this game yeah one is gonna Happy's not
in here actually and then are we gonna
have a post cap world or is this gonna
be like you know is he gonna come back
at some kind of later moment to surprise
you or show up this yeah Matt or
something I imagine so because this has
to just be actually one of the video
game that they showed us it was like
it's very bright it's very colorful some
of the graphics on like honestly this is
one of those games where when you see
the humans I'm not exactly amped Ferdie
this was the best looking human graphics
a little photo realistic for a game like
this I really just care about when I
play as lore do I get to do a bunch of
really cool Thor things so I get to do a
bunch of really cool Iron Man things and
I do want an enticing enough story and
there's plenty of questions and mystery
that they left here I like that when
they're marketing this specific game
they're still leading first and foremost
that this is gonna be a game worth
playing for its storyline as well and
not just a bunch of cool maneuvers you
can do oh yeah I mean and that's that's
the thing is this isn't the most
visually dazzling trailer I've seen all
e3 but I do think that yeah in an
Avengers game in a game where you're
already really familiar with the world
with the characters I feel like you can
lend a little leeway to that if that
effort goes into other aspects of the
game and one
that seems really exciting to me
especially looking this is a gameplay or
it looks like a you know gameplay
simulation heavy trailer and they've
been hyping up the fact that you could
have like a four-person co-op with this
you can customize your controls and the
end of your abilities and stuff that
aspect seems like it's gonna be really
fun and exciting because then you
probably really can coordinate like an
actual Avengers team with your buds and
and all have something different to do
here and I know that Square Enix this is
like a partnership with Marvel so Marvel
has weighed in on creating an original
storyline for this and this is part of
like a multi game deal so it seems like
they want to really throw down and have
this be something that's going to spawn
you know more and more games so it's
true seems like the pressures on because
they gotta make something really good at
you gotta make something truly gripping
and like going back to Spider Man they
have a grip I feel like the graphics in
spider-man are top-notch but it's story
is as equally or if not more captivating
than the designs and graphics alone I
like that there's the wait in the
trailer you know it takes a little bit
of a mind shift for me because I you
know I saw endgame three times not long
ago and then you go back to here we're
like oh it kind of looks like a vendor's
assemble at the time my question though
is you know they tease some like there's
something coming out of the ground at
the end but then also at the beginning
of this they have a narrator and I keep
wondering like who's this narrator they
keep talking to talking to this trailer
about they say shouldn't meet your
heroes I met my heroes it's great until
everything what's a sure I think then
who's that character yeah I think that's
the same voice from the tease too or we
see like you know the gauntlet smashed
and the shield crushed and you know
everyone the aftermath of the explosion
so I have to imagine that's gonna be a
character unless it's just some kind of
device I really like the whole aesthetic
they've come up with here because yeah
it's like on the heels of endgame this
does seem like a pretty devastating
event and to have it be like that little
detail of a day you know like an
infinite Jers daddy day yeah something
that's supposed to be a celebration has
now gone down and infamy yeah so like
yeah I think they have managed even
though this is again a tactically
focused trailer I think they have
intrigued me with what the story is
gonna be you know running underneath all
that yeah there's a lot of weight to it
and I felt like I was more ripped by the
last half of it because and the first
half of this did feel a little too
cartoony
having a little bit difficulty
readjusting to the graphics even though
I'm giving it a pass
considering all involved in considering
that no I'll ban today a really some of
marble shale that's they wanted to get a
little piece to like it looked like they
wanted to get across the humor and the
kind of action you're gonna be doing but
they cut it a bit too much they should
have let it maybe fluidly play out or
something yeah and I wonder if this game
could ever truly satisfy there's been so
much hype and so much anticipation and
there's no real information revealed
about this game like nothing to finite
to go off of like this is clearly the
most who we've got it well yeah yeah and
I guess my one concern would be our our
players going to experience any kind of
uncanny valley I mean you have more time
to acclimate to a game obviously than a
fee but because the characters are
reminiscent enough of their film
counterparts I gotta imagine for some
people that's gonna be a bit of a
distraction yeah you know and you had to
combine that with perhaps not the
greatest graphics we've seen all week
some look better than others
Thor's face does not look as good as
Tony's yeah you know some of them look
better than others but still some of the
gameplay moments even like with the Hulk
of I love that little more Rick's that
guy looks like he's gonna be cold looks
like the best player to be used in
destroying uh was at the Golden Gate
Bridge look like one of the thing is too
is like this wasn't very heavy on it
didn't seem heavy on cutscene footage
and the thing at the top so these are
you know gameplay rendered graphics most
of this was cut scene footage no didn't
open up with this is like game rendered
gameplay rendered I think so yeah I mean
it looked more like scenes and it did
actual gameplay to me though I could be
wrong
either way I'm excited for this game I
feel like II you know it's like right
now we were watching this the second we
got uploaded it has 40,000 views the
second it's got six thousand likes I'm
curious to see over time how people are
gonna respond to this trailer because
right now right now I'm not like over
hyped by this didn't add to me like
being extra hype right now
okay that was cool I like it kind of
expected some better facial graphics but
you know we'll see where it goes from
here anyway guys are you still excited
for this game
how are you satisfied with this trailer
leave it in the comments below you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and we'll catch
you guys soon